you know although i have my ideas I
don't know if I would consider it is
having responsibility to make a certain
point here there in fact I'm just as
happy just presenting what I think is
what would our land or a lot of my work
it's almost the foundation of existence
it's it's it's moving from one place to
a better place is that simply now all of
all of the politics get involved because
of what's under that umbrella is
pioneering entrepreneuring at least
Ireland even social utopia is or maybe
even Colts but I like to approach that
as neutrally as I can and just have them
exist together if anything I'd hope to
flatten the read a bit more and again I
still just want to concentrate on the
movement from one place to another the
side effect of that usually historically
is the formation of a group and
depending on what group it is I could be
completely afraid of it or completely
won't join but usually that's not the
case I'm more interested in exploring
the trajectory of that as opposed to
presenting it as some sort of actual
truth interested in and interested in it
in theory
you